Hey there, welcome to 3Blue1Brown.
So, I make videos that animate math.
For a lot of them, I just try to find something kinda interesting or thought provoking,
not necessarily in the typical progression of subjects that a student would see in school.
To see what I mean there, check out some of the Recommended playlist.
Some of the channel, though, is more directly targeted at people
actually trying to learn a commonly taught subject.
For an example of what I mean there, check out the Essence of Linear Algebra series that I did.
I'll always be working on some other 'Essence of' series like this, so stay posted for more.
Now, when I say that these videos animate math, on the one hand, I mean that very directly;
things are explained with moving visuals and anthropomorphic kinda-cartoonish pi creatures,
but my hope here is that they animate math in another, more literal sense of giving life to the subject.
Math kinda gets a bad rap for being abstruse and inhuman,
and let's face it, a lot of it is symbol heavy and can be introduced in a pretty unmotivated way.
But the fact is, good math is nothing less than art.
I'm guessing a lot of you out there know that feeling
when you wrap your mind around a really clever argument
and it's got that very unique flavour of satisfaction.
And same goes for re-understanding something familiar, but in a novel or unexpected light.
Here, I'm just trying to do my part to share feelings like those with more people.
So take a look at some of the videos here,
and if you want to stay posted about new stuff,
or to just see new videos rather than this trailer whenever you come back to the page,
consider subscribing.